stepping up for what could be an ugly
fight Britain's drawn anger from China
with an offer to welcome in Hong Kong
residents if Beijing doesn't scrap new
security laws for the territory it's got
nothing to do with containment a new
Cold War anything like that it's simply
a matter of keeping living up to the
responsibilities that on both sides
we've we've undertaken the Foreign
Secretary even willing to accept real
economic pain we've extended this
because precisely because this this
offer very precisely because we're not
turning our back on the people of Hong
Kong equally we recognize China's a
large power a rising economic power and
is a leading member of the international
community I think the thing which will
take the shine if you like off that rise
not just the economic impact of Kovach
19 but also if it cannot live up to the
deals that it makes it comes down to an
issue of trust but does that matter
anymore you thought you said yourself
it's a it's a rising power soon to be
the world's largest economy it can hit
us much harder economically are you
willing to sacrifice potentially a trade
deal with China to stand up for your for
the UK values that's extending the bno
passport holder offer to come to the UK
in the way I described is not contingent
on a free trade deal or anything like
that we wouldn't allow that to be to get
in the way of us doing our living up to
our responsibilities as a matter of
principle and I think both for moral
reasons and national standing that's
really important international standing
that's really important that's not how
China sees it accusing the UK of
meddling in its internal affairs Hong
Kong's pro-beijing leader agrees the
international community and some of the
foreign governments have been adopting
blatant double standards in dealing with
this matter and commenting on this
matter
but this former British territory is
divided there's outrage among many at
the security legislation and fear of a
stronger crackdown on freedoms plans
blocked to mark 31 years since
pro-democracy campaigners were killed in
Tiananmen Square you leaders could
realize that supporting Hong Kong is not
about MP pro-china or not it's about
right or wrong it's certainly about a
clash of values of power and of will
there behind Sky News